[Music]  loyal faith in true  [Music]  clothes organics six of our northern  cities have fallen in a coordinated  attack their leader fights alongside of  which  crush these murderers your majesty every  family must contribute one man to fight  your war hero you've already made many  great sacrifices my father cannot fight  so I will take his place  so know that invaders will kill her if I  expose how power all people will kill  her when we take the Imperial City I  will take revenge for my father what is  your name soldier  [ __ ] commander Sona Quadro you will now  take the oath of the warrior  wait  release  [Music]  pretending to be something you're not  yet here I stand proof that there is a  place for people like us  a girl threatens our plants  a warrior  [Applause]  [Music]  you